les chéris c'est bientôt la fin de
l'émission et je voulais vous dire merci
non franchement merci à tous et Afida tu
as été incroyable dans le bail
qu'est-ce qu'il y a
je suis très émue j'aimerais qu'on
remercie Cyril déjà on a besoin
de cette expérience
de chanter dans une gare sans répétition
ça prend beaucoup de cœur beaucoup de
risques parce que je m'étais habillé
pour un plateau vous imaginez en body en
latex en résine dans une gare sans
répétition mais elle a des dettes
c'est vraiment la vraie fête de la
musique des choses improbables i love it
thank you
il reste encore des images t'inquiète
pas ma chérie l'émission l'émission
n'est pas finie reste encore des images
oui t'inquiète pas parce qu'on a été à
la fête de la musique
en fait on était sur la tête de la
musique et après on sera sur vous vous
irez chacun un dernier petit mot avant
de partir on fait le dernier magnéto de
la salle de musique et après chacun
préparé un petit mot je sais pas si vous
avez un petit mot à dire à douter les
spectateurs parce que vous avez pas les
voir pendant 2 mois donc préparer et toi
aussi tu as si tu as un truc à dire ah
moi j'ai déjà prêt c'est quoi toi
merci à tous les téléspectateurs merci à
C8 merci à ces moments fantastiques
merci à Dieu parce que son Dieu nous
serons pas là et aimer tous les gens que
vous aimez parce que vous savez jamais
quand c'est la dernière fois que vous
voyez les
êtres c'est très important j'ai perdu
beaucoup de d'être aimé ces trois
dernières mois et à my friends arrêtez
de faire des jaloux là derrière là et
thank you va le mettre et Happy fait de
la musique dans une gare
[Applaudissements]
avant que je me dise un petit bout les
chéris c'était des amours à la fête de
mix qu'ils avaient tous un petit bout
pour moi regardez
c'était la fête de la musique mais
c'était surtout l'occasion de dire au
revoir à Baba et de lui souhaiter de
bonnes vacances
Cyril et même si on n'est pas toujours
d'accord avec lui c'est sympa de donner
la parole à des gens savoir ce qu'ils
ont vécu leurs ressenti donc voilà passe
une bonne soirée Cyril je t'aime Cyril
Hanouna the best Cyril Michael huissier
moi on te souhaite des meilleurs
vacances possible comment ça va ça va
beaucoup pour la fête de la musique
chocolat chaud
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chocolat